If you’ve ever had a car break down and
a mechanic tells you that you’ve got a busted
thingy-ma-bob, you’ll probably pay the man
and get the part?
But what about us?
What happens if one of our 206 bones break?
Can i get new one?
If you break a bone, you go to the doctor
and you get a cast.
Then your bone heals itself.
Which is actually pretty incredible if you
stop and think about it…
We tend to think of bones as these rigid support
systems, but they’re actually made of living
tissue!
Bones are constantly breaking down and remodeling
themselves to adapt to your lifestyle -- if
you go from playing video games on your couch
to marathon running, your bones are going
to change to compensate!
It’s pretty incredible -- and scientists
call this adapting: Wolff’s law.
So, if I just started marathon running and
break a bone I’m not out of luck.
The body knows exactly what to do: it produces
tons of new cells at the site of the break
to rebuild the bone over time.
But if you have cancer, a genetic defect,
or if something really bad happens -- like,
a break is so bad that than the body can’t
heal it on its own… scientists finally have
a way to repair bones that befall these situations
too…
Biomedical researchers are figuring out how
to grow bones from a patient's own cells!
This may sound straight out of a frankenstein
novel but it’s actually happening!
First, they take a CT scan of the patient’s
damaged bone and 3D-print a custom scaffold
to fit in the space.
Then, they'll take fat tissue from a patient
and extract stem cells from it.
Stem cells are these fabulous blank slates
that can be programmed to do just about anything,
including bone regeneration.
Next, they take their scaffold and the extracted
stem cells into a bioreactor … which is
a fancy incubator that feeds nutrients to
the stem cells and mimics the conditions inside
the body.
And… that’s it.
We’re now growing bones!
After a few weeks, viola! … a lab grown
human bone!
But don’t get too excited.
So far, biomedical engineers only have a proof
of concept.
They’ve conducted successful trials in pigs
and are preparing for human trials in the
future.
Tissue engineering is a crazy exciting field
when you think of all the possibilities!
In the future, if you need a new organ or
body part, you won’t have to wait in line
for a donor organ that may or may not even
work in your body -- you’ll be able to use
your own cells to customize new body parts!
We could live forever!Though… at the moment
bone fixes are a bit more Medieval.
There are three main ways we fix bones now:
we snag some animal bones, grab them from
dead persons or cadavers, or just use good
old-fashioned metal implants.
These three options are not ideal because
they can cause infections, or could be rejected
by the body.
They are, however, considered bioinert, meaning
the body accepts the new part but the addition
doesn’t necessarily support the rest of
your body.
For instance, titanium implants don’t have
bone marrow, so that implant won’t help
you grow new blood or immune cells.
There is actually a fourth option… taking
a piece of bone from your own body!
But, it’s horrifying.
It requires invasive surgery, where doctors
make an incision in a part of your hip bone
called the iliac crest, and they use a mallet
and chisel to harvest a piece of that bone
which they then can use in reconstructive
surgery.
Stop it hurts.
This autologous bone grafting is super painful
and sometimes risky.
So the promise of lab-grown bones gets around
all these things.
These lab-grown thingys are just… bones!
They grow marrow, don’t require thieving
bones or parts from you or other organisms,
and because it’s made from the patient’s
own cells, there’s no chance of rejection.
It’s fully customizable to what you need!
Which is pretty awesome.
A biomedical engineer on the forefront of
this research claims lab grown bones are changing
everything, because the body becomes a [quote]
“vast renewable resource.”
So, even though they’re not ready now, there
may come a point when we could keep growing
our own parts again and again and again!
Like Harry Potter’s Skelegrow!
Madam Pomfrey would be pleased as punch.
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain dot
com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
If you knew you could just, grow more bones
-- would you be way riskier?
Try extreme sports or jump off stuff, because
WHY NOT?
Let us know in the comments.
Did you know bone marrow grows blood?
Yep.
It's weird.
We've got a video about it right here.
So be sure to like this video and subscribe
so you never miss an episode of Seeker.